madame monsieurs bonjour et bienvenue
pour la suite de nos débats consacrés
aux élections départementales du mois de
mars après la Nièvre samedi dernier nous
allons nous intéresser aujourd'hui à
Lyonne dans cette émission réalisée en
partenariat avec Lyonne républicaine que
vous représentezen V Crass bonjour
bonjouron 342000 500 habitants 42
Conseillers généraux avant cette
élection 42 Conseillers généraux après
ou plutôt conseillers départementaux CQ
femmes élu avant 21 après voilà ce qui
va peut-être le plus changer après ces
élections quoi qu'il en soit pour
débattre des enjeux de ces élections
départementales nous accueillons cinq
candidats qui représentent tous des
cantons différents André Villier bonjour
bonjour vous êtes le président sortant
et vous êtes udi Gérard Delom bonjour
pour le Parti socialiste et ses alliés
du groupe axi ambition citoyenne et
solidaire de Lyonne Jean-Baptiste le
mooine bonjour bonjour sénateur
conseiller général sortant on vous prête
beaucoup d'ambition pour cette élection
on y reviendra Chantal doucar bonjour
bonjour vous êtes conseillère régionale
et candidate de l'alliance entre Europe
Écologie les vers et le Front de gauche
et puis Julien audou bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidat du Front national
parti que vous avez rejoint récemment he
au mois de décembre à la Maison vous
pouvez déc pardon non non à l'été l'été
dernier l'été dernier ah bon alors on
ait une mauvaise information à la maison
vous pouvez réagir ou commenter ce débat
via Twitter
hashtaglvel Bourgogne ou at F3 Bourgogne
ou sur notre page facebook bien sûr
André Villier on se souvient tous de la
bataille de
2011 bataille pendant laquelle vous avez
réussi à à prendre la tête du conseil
général en lieu et place de de l'UMP
Jean-Marie
Rolland quelques années plus tard
qu'est-ce que vous vous dites j'ai bien
fait j'ai un bon bilan euh alors j'ai
bien fait et j'ai envie de continuer uer
voilà pour être clair pour le bilan
alors le bilan il est il est très
satisfaisant dans un contexte de crise
qui n'échappe à personne en matière
d'aménagement du territoire je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres et on est bien
obligé d'aborder le budget puisque c'est
l'exercice principal d'une collectivité
territoriale donc en 4 ans nous avons
investi près de 170 millions dans
l'aménagement du territoire pour le
compte propre du conseil général mais
aussi pour l'ensemble des communes du
département donc je vais pas entrer dans
le détail mais ce sont des des chiffres
significatifs nous avons également
investi un certain nombre de millions
d'euros 50 sur ces 4 années au titre de
du développement économique en soutenant
les entreprises du département les
agriculteurs les artisans et en
utilisant les moyens qui sont les ntres
c'est-à-dire nos satellites je veux
parler de y développement la société
d'économie mixte y équipement et y
active création et puis en matière
d'éducation nous ne sommes pas en rest
puisque c'est sans plus 130 millions
d'euros au titre des transports et en
particulier des transports scolaires
mais nul doute que nous reviendrons sur
sur le sujet 83 millions dépensés pour
l'entretien des des des routes et puis
comment ne pas parler du sujet principal
des départements puisqu'il s'agit vous
le savez bien de la dimension de la
solidarité départementale et je veux
vous citer un chiffre que nous évoquions
tout à l'heure en studio le département
de Lyonne injecte sur le territoire
départemental chaque jour près de 600000
€ au titre de la solidarité
départementale tout ça dans un contexte
où évidemment la dimension budgétaire
prime nous devons faire face à un
endettement important qui est le
résultat d'engagement antérieur que les
Présidents de Conseils généraux qui
m'ont précédé ont bien dû à la fois
engager et suivre ces 245 millions donc
aujourd'hui nous contenons cette cette
dette nous ne l'augmentons pas et puis
nous évitons de recourir le plus
possible à la fiscal qualité vous avez
envie de m'arriter c'est ça oui on va
détailler tout ça on va détailler tout
ça pendant l'émission
monsieur Chantal doucar même question
peut-être votre vision de du bilan de
cette mandature et à travers ça votre
vision du du territoire de Lyonne oui
alors j'ai bien entendu tous les
chiffres donnés par le président du
conseil général sortant et il y a eu
effectivement beaucoup d'investissements
mais je crois que ce qui intéresse
vraiment les électeurs c'est le résultat
de tout cela et moi j'aurais plus envie
de parler en terme d'image de notre
département et de dire que l'image du
département de Lyonne est quand même un
petit peu
inquiétante il y a quand même des
phénomènes préoccupants par exemple au
niveau de la
démographie je crois que tout le monde
constate que Lyonne n'est pas un
département particulièrement attirant et
que la jeunesse en
particulier est très pressé souvent de
quitter nos territoires au contraire les
personnes âgées on a une population
vieillissante avec tous les problèmes
toutes les questions que ça peut poser
au niveau de l'éducation et bien Lyon
est extrêmement mal placé du point de
vue scolaire et je ne pense pas pourtant
que nos élèves que les jeunes soit moins
méritant que dans les autres
départements mais il faut bien dire à
qui la faute madame dou il faut bien
dire qu'au niveau national le
département ne brille pas par ses
résultats les entreprises fu Lyon
beaucoup d'entreprises se sont arrêtées
je citerai deux entreprises Fulmen ccli
qui n'ont pas été tellement aidé non
plus par le département lorsqu'ells ont
eu leur difficultés et puis je
terminerai aussi par quelque chose de
très inquiétant c'est la qualité de
l'eau nous sommes vraiment dans le rouge
tous les captages de Lyonne sont en
rouge il y a régulièrement des communes
qui ne peuvent plus distribuer d'eau
potable à leurs administrés donc pour
moi le bilan est un petit peu inqui é
temp alors je ne dis pas que le Conseil
général est responsable de tout ça euh
mais on peut pas dire qu'il n'a pas non
plus de responsabilité on sait qu'il y a
eu des transferts de compétences qui se
sont effectués dans les années qui ont
passé avec des moyens qui n'étaient pas
suffisants l'État s'est désengagé on
sait aussi qu'il y a une politique
d'austérité récente qui réduit les
budgets et les moyens des collectivités
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord mais il
n'empêche que le Conseil général a une
responsab il ité
essentielle dans dans ces résultats je
terminerai si vous permettez par une
note très positive par contre au niveau
du conseil général et je le féliciterai
d'avoir pris très récemment une motion à
propos du projet tafta de grand marché
très transatlantique qui est un projet
dont on parle trop peu et qui pourtant
va impacter si jamais il aboutit qui va
impacter l'ensemble de nos collectivités
et dans un sens extrêmement négatif ou
accord entre les États-Unis on va dire
et et et l'Union européenne exactement
Jean-Baptiste Le moind alors vous êtes
je l'ai pas précisé tout à l'heure
vice-président sortant aussi est-ce que
vous regarder finalement le le bilan de
façon tout à fait positive ou plus de
façon plus négative comme Chantal en
faisant la synthèse des deux
interventions précédentes on voit bien
que le département conserve un rôle
important et et à mes yeux doit le
conserver or on est en train d'organiser
le déussement systématique du
département voilà quelle est
effectivement la politique menée par ce
gouvernement qui et bien je crois pent
des coups dures à la ruralité en voulant
vider de leur substance effectivement le
département les communes qui pourtant
sont des instances de proximité et qui
peuvent répondre à un certain nombre de
préoccupations de de des icon sur vos
actions à vous alors alors moi sur mes
actions à moi je suis je conseil général
justement j'étais en charge au sein de
et bien de ce mandat sortant mon premier
mandat du tourisme notamment je suis
ravi qu'on ait pu avoir décroché un pôle
d'excellence rurale touristique dans
dans le départ
bre à Paris pour aller chercher cet
argent on l'a eu ravi de de prendre le
virage numérique aussi avec avec
tourisme et puis je parle devant un
président d'office de tourisme
également procéder à la modernisation de
notre outil avec la fusion de y tourisme
et des unions départementales d'office
de tourisme donc voilà pour ma part
satisfait d'avoir pu mener cette action
à la fois
modernisatrice et puis dans dans dans
dans nos cantons respectifs on a tous je
crois di satisfaction pour ma part celui
d'avoir sauvé la maison de retraite
Saint-Joseph à cherrois et d'avoir pu
augmenter le nombre de lits alors ça
n'empêche pas les dissensions mais on y
reviendra peut-être plus tard dans le
dans le cours de de cette émission
Gérard deorme oui moi je comprends tout
à fait que André Villier et jean-
Baptiste l mooine défendent leur bilan
puisque il est le leur et et je
comprendrai pas qu'il en soit autrement
cependant je moi c'est plutôt un constat
que je vais faire c'est le constat que
font les iconais quand ils regardent
leur le feuille d'impôt les impôts du
département ont quasiment doublé depuis
2001 et ça c'est une réalité c'est vrai
aussi pour la dette vous avez voudrais
vous dire que je suis né en 2011 oui non
mais je sais bien mais c'était aussi la
droite quic c'était aussi la droite qui
était aux affaires du département à
cette époque et on peut pas dire que
François Hollande soit responsable
puisqueaujourd'hui on tend à lui faire
porter quelques responsabilité sur
l'évolution du département mais on a
parlera tout à l'heure restons sur le
sur le bilan la dette a également
augmenté de façon considérable
puisqu'elle était de 145 millions
d'euros en 2008 elle est de 247 millions
aujourd'hui je crois que ce sont des
chiffres exacts de 2008 à 2011 soyez
précis de 2008 à 2014 de 2008 à 2011 les
chiffres sont étus ils sont étus bon
mais en tout cas vous pouvez pas dire
comme vous l'avez souligné tout à
l'heure que le départe que la dette du
département n'augmentait pasmoi je
retiendrai si vous permettez aussi un
énorme gâi alors ça tient bien à la
mandature dans André Villier c'est la
situation à domanis et on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure où
il y a un véritable enjeu mais c'est on
est bien dans le bilan et également en
matière culturelle en matière de
transport voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui
il faut être un peu plus modeste quant à
la réussite de la gestion du département
ces deux dernières années et bien
au-delà je rappelle que le département
est à droite depuis de très très
nombreuses années c'est historique
julienoule je peux dire que vous êtes
nouveau vous n'alz pas me cont j'ai pas
de bilan moi en tout cas je n'ai pas de
bilan nouveau dans ce département c'est
la première fois que vous vous présentez
ici comment vous voyez justement ce
bilance cette politique dans
départementjà Monsieur PSO j'aimerais
relever si vous voulez bien l'absurdité
de ce scrutin départemental qui est
assez bien illustré sur ce plateau
puisque madame doucar est la seule femme
donc présente donc contre quatre hommes
donc la parité finalement qui était
voulue par le gouvernement AC ce scrutin
binominal donc paritaire est une parité
de façade et ce qu'on observe ve dans
bon nombre de cantons c'est que ce sont
toujours les hommes finalement qui qui
sont les candidats principaux et que
l'UMP éant le PS font du
remplissage avec donc des des candidates
quiandz que la parité se situe à gauche
sur ce banc alors qu'à droite on fait le
constat effectivement vous avez du mal
sil vous
plat la parité à gauche c'est quandme on
é plutôt sur le vilan monsieur et
ensuite je suis j'étais assez atterré en
faire des propos de Monsieur Villier euh
je dirais que que Monsieur Villier se
représente donc à ses élections et par
la mme occasion brigue la présidence du
conseil départemental après le bilan
désastreux la banque-route de domanis je
trouve ça profondément scandaleux TR
profondément Scand et insultant pour les
iconaises et les iconais donc on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais je trouve
que c'est un une banque route qui aurait
dû finalement vous aurez dû en tirer les
conséquences en démissionnant tout
simplement parce que on ne peut pas
rester à la tête d'un exécutif local
après cette situation alors puisque
monsieur Odou parle de domanis
effectivement domanis s'est enfoncé he
ces dernières années ça a été compliqué
qu'est-ce que on va faire aujourd'hui
pour alors écoutz moi en réponse à la
fois je de l'orme et à monsieurou je
précise quand même pour les
téléspectateurs que domanis c'est le
bailleur social qui gère c'est le
bailleur social dont Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine vient de prendre la avec bonheur
la la présidence et je voudrais dire que
en 2012 lorsque la difficulté nous a été
révélée monsieur Odou c'est un peu de
l'histoire départementale mais comme
vous connaissez pas le département je
voudrais vous en dire un mot con très
bien monsieur le département non non je
pense que vous venez de plus loin que
les frontières du département et vous
méritez en tant qu'historien peut-être
de porter un regard plus précis sur le
département et c'est la raison de ma
réponse donc en tout cas je voudrais
vous dire que les difficultés de domanis
sont du malgré un conseil
d'administration extrêmement musclé qui
met en présence à ce moment-là des gens
de gauche et de droite le maire d'osser
par exemple le responsable des finances
actuelles de la ville d'osser la caiss
Dépôts et Consignation personne mais
personne ne voit venir les difficultés
de domanis depuis 200ende sil vous plat
200 en 2012 en 2012 les choses sont
révélées et à ce moment-là il faut
sauver le bailleur social et on se
tourne très naturellement vers le
conseil général qui décide y compris
avec les voix de l'opposition de venir
en aide au bailleurs social pour éviter
justement la vente à villeprix des 9000
logements qui constituent le parc du
bailleur social c'est ça qui s'est passé
et c'est 5 millions qui ont été jecté en
plusieurs années moi aujourd'hui je
prends attendez je vais au bout quand
même parce que c'est très important et
que les téléspectateurs comprennent bien
ce dont il s'agit et que surtout
monsieur Odoul apprenne un peu
l'histoire du département qu'est-ce qui
se passe à ce moment-là et bien le
département injecte 5 millions d'euros
progressivement sur 6 ans avec la caisse
du logement social et aujourd'hui
domanis est revenu à meilleure fortune
et je vais demander si je suis reconduit
à la présidence un réexamin des comptes
et un remboursement au département des
sommes qui ont été précomté et avancé
pour sauver le bailleur social voilà
c'est un sauvchage d'entreprise monsieur
Odou c'est tout simplement ce dont il
s'agit vous avez protégé monsieur Drouin
donc votre ami voilà qui est quand même
suspecté je dirais à bien des égards de
clientélisme et d'avoir profité
largement donc de des enveloppes domanis
donc monsieur viler arrêté ne
brandisseit pas cette défense qui est
totalement ridicule au regarde la
situation de domanis madame je crois
voulez Inter sur le le sujet et bien
j'entends monsieur Villier nous dire que
si j'ai bien compris hein 5 ou 6
millions c'est ça de 5 millions d'euros
ont été réinjectés par le pas
complètement on est à TR aujourd'hui
d'accord on est à TR et et le bailleur
social est en train de revenir à
meilleure fortune donc la situation
mérite d'être regardé et moi j'entends
s'agissant de fonds public demander des
comptes au groupes d'homanis et que
l'argent public qui a été investi
revienne au contribuable départemental
tout à fait mais si je pose la question
c'est parce que au-delà du problème de
fond de cette cette affaire il y a aussi
un problème je dirais de transparence de
l'information parce que si j'ai j'ai
bien lu liyonne républicaine on est
passé par des évaluations assez
changeantes on a parlé d'un déficit de
10 millions de 15 millions de 20
millions donc euh peut-être que là
maintenant que nous sommes à l'heure du
bilan il serait temps que les iconais
sachent exactement quelle est la facture
quel a quel a été le véritable montant
du déficit de de de domanis est-ce que
vous pouvez nous informer alors Monsieur
le MO peut-être puisque vous venez de
prendre la alors non mais pour faire
simple à un moment il y a un organisme
qui a eu les yeux plus gros que le
ventre voilà bon il y a eu donc du coup
de nombreux achats de terrain euh de
construction et effectivement
l'organisme n'avait pas un lesin assez
solide alors ça c'est une période c'est
le passé et quelque part moi j'ai pris
la présidence il y a 9 mois parce que
personne voulait y aller et je veux pas
regarder le passé maintenant ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment on fait
effectivement pour redresser la boutique
pour permettre d'offrir un cadre de vie
qui soit un cadre de vie qui soit et
bien à la hauteur de ce que peuvent
attendre nos locataires
voà et donc le département a mis
effectivement 5 millions d'euros la les
organismes de tutelle ont mis 5 millions
d'euros au niveau national et puis
maintenant maintenant on fait tous nos
efforts pour arriver justement à à cider
une partie du patrimoine et je peux vous
dire que 2014 est une année historique
de ce point de vue-là où on a même
augmenter de 37 % le produit des cession
et puis surtout on travaille pour
améliorer on lutte contre la vacance
faire en sorte que les logements ne
restent pas vides trop longtemps on
lutte contre les impayés et donc
effectivement le personnel fait a fait
de gros
efforts on est passé
de à une voilure qui est de 210 salariés
là où il y en avait plus avant donc tout
ça commence à produire ses efforts et ça
été le fruit de de de tout le monde
alors maintenant euh j'entends ce que
dit président du conseil général j'ai
dis attention cependant euh nous sommes
encore en phase de surveillance et on ne
peut pas retirer comme ça du jour au
lendemain x million d'euros qui voilà
qui ont été actés dans un protocole avec
l'État et cetera mais donc sachez que
vraiment la situation est en train de
revenir effectivement à la normale et on
va réinvestir ça va être bon aussi pour
l'emploi local pour la première fois on
va mettre 27 millions d'euros sur la
table en 2015 c'est pas rien pour les
entreprises locales on avance parce que
c'est pas le seul sujet je pourrais
rajouter un point peut-être rajouter un
point
sagissant de logement je trouve que
monsieurou est un SDF de la politique
cont tenu de son parcours
politique récent il nous montre qu'il
sait pas très bien se situer donc voilà
je voulais profiter quand même du
logement une petite allusion monsieur
vous aurez l'occasion de répondre c'est
sûr tout à l'heure on parlera de la
situation du Front national juste un
petit mot de de G sur le sujet avant
qu'on passere chose vousou qui va sur un
chemin qui ne mène nulle part mais je
voulais simplement revenir mais moi je
pense que le travail qui été il était
courageux Jean-Baptiste Le mooine de
reprendre domanis et c'est vrai que si
l'opposition a s'est investi aussi pour
aider le logement social c'est quelque
chose auquel on est très attaché si on n
pas d'opérateur et ben c'est tout le
logement social dans le département qui
P analiser mais pas seulement pas
seulement c'est toute l'entreprise c'est
tout le milieu du bâtiment et je sais
que Jean-Baptiste Le mooine a comme binô
la présidente de la Fédération du
bâtiment et là c'est la difficulté elle
est aussi à ce niveau et les entreprises
du départte du bâtiment du département
sont aujourd'hui cruellement touchés et
c'est une conséquence de la situation
chez domanis madame je vais vous donner
la parole mais peut-être sur un autre
thème parce qu'ilut non je voulais je
voulais quand même une précision donc
j'ai entendu parler de 5 millions ici 5
millions là donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire que clairement le déficit était
seulement de 10 millions parce que j'ai
pas eu exactement la
réponse pardonnez-moi parce que je pense
qu'il est bien effectivement d'avancer
de voir comment on va résoudre la
situation c'est ce que propose monsieur
le moine mais il est bien aussi quand
même que que les citoyens soient
informés exactement de ce qui s'est
passé on donne ce chire 31 mlions dit
monsur cétait combien le déficit
vraiment on est autour de 25 hein 25
allez on peut passer à 25 millions
d'argent public
donc pour rester sur le la thématique du
du social si vous voulez bien on va
évoquer le le le dossier que qu'évoquait
André viler tout à l'heure sur le le
l'aide sociale et la politique d'action
sociale du du conseil général on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le le l'action sociale
représente la moitié du du budget du du
département 205 millions millions
d'euros à l'heure actuelle André Villier
vous vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe craignez-vous aujourd'hui ou en
tout cas pensez-vous qu'avec un budget
qui qui qui grandit sur le la politique
d'action sociale le département a encore
des leviers encore des des marges de
manœuvre sur d'autres thèmes pour les
les
territoires ça c'est la question de fond
l'équilibre budgétaire du département de
Lyonne mais de de l'ensemble des
départements sur un sujet comme celui-là
dans un contexte dont je rappelle qu'il
est un contexte de crise et qui voit
grossir les dépenses sociales à travers
plusieurs paramètres la structure
principale on va pas entrer trop dans le
détail il faudrait y passer l'émission
entière mais la structure principale du
budget de l'action sociale c'est trois
aides individuelles de solidarité c'est
l'Allocation Personnalisée à l'Autonomie
la prime compensatrice au handicap et le
revenu de solidarité active je vais
m'arrêter sur le dernier sujet pour
lequel et bien nous sommes à peu près à
11700 bénéficiaires dans Lyonne et il y
a là la résultante d'une crise
économique profonde avec ses
conséquences social puisque le
département de Lyonne compte
aujourd'hui à peu près 17000 demandeurs
d'emploi et que au terme des durées
d'indemnisation du chômage et bien ces
personnes sont conduits vers les minimas
sociaux vers le RSA et que
l'augmentation du RSA sur le dernier
exercice il est de 10 % si on tient
compte également des revalorisations
donc il y a là un véritable sujet
d'inquiétude puisque les
euh les recettes qui nous proviennent de
l'État en compensation sont en
diminution je ne sais pas si vous pouvez
à l'écran non on peut pas regardez
regardez une courbe mais entre 2009 et
aujourd'hui le reste à charge pour le
département de Lyonne sur ces trois
allocations il passe en 2009 de 25
millions à 45 millions aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que c'est le département
sur ses propres ressources qui doit
aller puiser précisément les moyens
nécessaires pour servir ces allocations
c'est un véritable sujet et aujourd'hui
et bien si nous gardons la compétence
sociale il faut absolument que les
pouvoirs publics nous apporte l'aide
nécessaire à la conduite de cette
politique monsieur Odou on entend
finalement très peu votre votre
programme dans quelqu département que ce
soit là-dessus quel est votre quelles
sont vos ambitions alors justement
expliquez-nous déjà sur les sur les
compétences sociales du département
faudrait savoir si on les garde ou pas
parce que a priori on s'oriente non mais
parce que nos concitoyens doivent savoir
que quand même que c'est la première
première fois dans l'histoire de la
République où nous allons voter
finalement pour une institution dont
nous ignorons totalement les compétences
voilà et finalement les médias par en
parle très peu et c'est totalement
totalement aberrent est- est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on les gardera ça
c'est c'est une chose après le le à mon
sens et au sens du Front national le
département doit rester le l'institution
de la proximité et la proximité bien sûr
c'est sociale c'est la petite enfance
c'est les personnes âgées c'est les
personnes handicapées et il faut bien
sûr renforcer ce ce ce volet là mais il
faut aussi qu'il ait des compétences
économiques faut que le département soit
en capacité d'aider l'emploi d'aider les
entreprises pour que faire en sorte de
baisser le nombre
de comment détenteurs du RSA voilà sinon
vous avez un nombre de de D denteurs du
RSA qui va augmenter et un département
qui va s'endetter Gérard Delor peut-être
sur les les compétences du département
effectivement encore entouré de de de
flou et sur le poids de de de de cette
politique sociale dans le Budet
poids de la solidarité ça restera de
toute façon au département je crois que
c'est un enjeu fort mais ça va au-delà
du guichet ça va au-delà du Guchet je
crois que le département a un effort à
faire aussi auprès des associations qui
viennent en soutien pour la mobilité par
exemple pour le le lien on a on parlait
d'assistante sociale on parle
d'assistana l'assistana non moi j'y
crois pas mais l'assistante sociale a un
rôle aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que le
département doit aider aussi dans ce
domaine dans le domaine par rapport au
au au professionnels sociaux qui
viennent dans les territoires pour aider
les gens à retrouver un emploi et ça
aujourd'hui on n pas de structure qui
permettent d'aller dans ce sens-là et ça
ce serait une de vos propositions ça
serait une de nos propositions parce que
c'est c'est bien beau d'avoir d'avoir
d'avoir de l'argent à distribuer même si
ça ça pèse de plus en plus sur les
finances du département il faut voir
derrière comment ça peut se concrétiser
c'est-à-dire qu'on ait d'autres actions
qui ne soient pas des actions de de
guichet mais qui viennent aider
justement le retour à l'emploi par
rapport à la mobilité et d'autres
actions vous avez un point commun avec
votre voisine avec le Front de Gauche
c'est que vous proposer la gratuité le
retour à la gratuité des transports
scolaires que vous avez arrêté monsieur
Viller le Conseil général a les moyens
le je pose la question aux deux je
commence si le le Conseil général doit
se donner les moyen parce qu'aujourd'hui
vous parlez d'équité dans dans le
territoire et il y a un véritable
déséquilibre quel son les familles qui
sont pénalisées par l'arrêt de la
gratuité des transports scolaires ce
sont les familles de la ruralité c'est
cell vous prétendez les défendre moi je
dis non parce que là il y a un véritable
déséquilibre et pour ces famillesl qui
ont plusieurs enfants par exemple il y a
un véritable coût qui est pas prise en
charge par le département et là
effectivement ça sera une de nos
priorités rétablir la gratuité du
transport scolaire mais aussi avoir une
véritable réflexion sur la mobilité ça
va bien au-delà on parlera peut-être des
transports tout tout à l'heure mais
au-delà des transports scolaires il y a
toute une réflexion à mener sur la
mobilité dans le département et
intradépartement parce que il y a une
réflexion qui sera peut-être porté à
l'échelle régionale au niveau des
transports collectifs madame docard
peut-être juste avant que vilier oui sur
la politique de de solidarité je
voudrais effectivement revenir sur
quelque chose je d'une part je suis
d'accord effectivement avec mon voisin
en ce qui concerne le manque
véritablement d'encadrement au niveau
social c'est-à-dire que ça fait déjà des
années et avant la M la présidence
d'André Villier que le territoire manque
de travailleurs sociaux que les
assistants sociaux ou les assistantes
sociales euh parce que c'est pas une
profession seulement féminine ont
quasiment disparu en particulier les
zones rurales mais ça s'est plutôt
aggravé ces derniers temps les
animateurs de rue par exemple à oser qui
étaient quatre sur les quatre il en
reste aujourd'hui un je crois que ça n'a
plus aucune signification quand on
arrive à ce chiffre là mais je voudrais
revenir sur quelque chose qui nous
ramène un petit peu excusez et moi à
domanis et plutôt à la question du
logement parce que là non je veux pas
revenir sur domanis mais je veux revenir
sur la question du logement parce que au
niveau de la solidarité il y a un
problème qui est crucial dans le
département c'est le le problème de la
précarité énergétique pour des familles
qui sont de plus en plus en difficulté
qui n'arrivent pas à régler leur facture
d'énergie et ça c'est un véritable
gouffre financier je sais que les élus
du conseil général qui qui sont en
charge de ces dossiers s'en inquiète et
je crois que là il y a une une action
urgente absolument urgente à mener parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer à investir
des sommes dans un puits sans fonds sans
prendre des mesures pour boucher ses
trous on est véritablement devant un
problème qui est un problème économique
financier pour la collectivité mais on
sait bien que c'est un problème beaucoup
plus large que ça puisque c'est un
problème qui est en rapport avec le
changement climatique contre lequel
normalement nos collectivités sont
censées se mobiliser donc il y a un
véritable plan de rénovation d'aide à la
rénovation thermique qui doit être mis
en mis en place pour ces logements qui
sont véritablement des passoirs
énergétiques et je m'interroge mais je
n'ai pas les réponses peut-être que
Monsieur Villier ou monsieur le mooine
vont me les donner sur la qualité réelle
des des bâtiment proposé par domanis en
terme d'économie d'énergie en terme de
de qualité
énergétique la parole à monsur dit mais
je voulais revenir comme Madame doucar
sur la politique sociale et c'est vrai
que c'est la moitié des dépenses
département
euh ça va continuer dans ce sens-là
parce qu'on doit apporter une réponse à
nos aînés par exemple soit pour le
maintien à domicile ou dans dans les
épades il y a un certain obligations et
il y a également un reste à charge ça a
été dit considérable de la part de
l'État une une ardoise hallucinante donc
40 millions d'euros bon
maintenant il y a également on voit un
problème de consentement à l'impôt parce
que ça tombe depuis depuis 2 ans comme
un Gravelotte bon et et je crois que sur
le social euh n les iconnais attendent
aussi que il puisse y avoir une une
nutre contre la fraude sociale alors par
exemple sur le RSA dans le département
de Lyonne si on est précis en 2013 il y
a eu 81 cas de de de de fraude sociale
avéré qui ont été détecé sur ces 81 cas
8 ont fait l'objet de pénalité 73
d'avertissements je pense qu'il faudrait
peut-être inverser le ratio parce que
les gens ne supportent pas quand en
moyenne 5200 € par exemple euh ont été
touchés de façon frauduleuse donc ça
c'est un point et moi je pense que le
Conseil général ça ça ça ça dans sa
nouvelle version conseil départemental
pourrait réfléchir au fait B voilà
d'avoir peut-être un contrôleur dédié
sur le RSA pour au côté de la CAF
accroître cette dimension et ainsi
récupérer de l'argent qui nous permettra
et bien de redéployer sur d'autres
politiques que ce soit le soutien aux
associations d'aide à domicile par
exemple on en a une quarantaine qui
parfois dans sont dans des situations
compliquées et qui sont pourtant des
maillons essentiels du bienvvre sur nos
territoires et puis puisque
effectivement madame dukar
m'interrogeait par rapport à domanis et
et et à la à la précarité énergétique il
faut savoir que nous allons mettre sur
la table cette année 8 millions d'euros
en renouvellement de composants pour
justement changer les fenêtres les
huisseries avoir des portes qui isolent
et cetera et c'est pas rien et c'est pas
rien euh et sachez que c'est seulement
15 % de l'isolation hein et par ailleurs
et par ailleurs euh nous allons cette
année avoir deux personnels en plus
comme conseillère d'économie sociale et
familiale pour justement prévenir les
situations pour éviter qu'on tombe dans
des situations compliquées monsieur
odoule vous aviez demandé la parole sur
CEET oui oui ben je rejoins tout à fait
Monsieur L moine sur le la volonté de de
lutter contre la fraude sociale qui est
une véritable gangraine tant au niveau
départemental qu'au niveau national
d'ailleurs c'est assez curieux que soit
un gouvernement de gauche qui ne fasse
rien contre pour lutter contre la fraude
sociale qui est quand même une injustice
majeure et puis ensuite puisqu'on
parlait de social le social ça doit
concerern les plus nécessiteux
notamment bah nos compatriotes du
département qui sont en en besoins et
non pas les élus du département
justement euh peut-être que vous ne le
savez pas mais donc il n'y a une caisse
de soutien pour les anciens conseillers
généraux de 330000 € donc voilà qui
constitue en fait une rente à vie pour
les anciens élus qui sont passés donc
par le par le département qui est
totalement scandaleuse au regard des
difficultés que connaissent nos
compatriotes voilà le social doit
concerner euh les habitants et non pas
les élus qui ne doivent pas se servir
des caisses du département donc pour se
faire une retraite dorée et sur la
politique oui vous allez répondre à
Monsieur vill et sur la politique en
général d'aide aux familles comment
est-ce que vous êtes notamment favorable
vous aussi au retour à la gratuité par
exemple pour les transports scolaires
alors non au Fond national nous sommes
contre la gratuité pour le par principe
c'estàd qu'un service public qui gratuit
c'est un service public qu'on ne
respecte pas et au final c'est un
service public qui meurt voilà de toute
façon un service public public n'est
jamais gratuit dans le sens où vous avez
du personnel à à payer vous avez bien
sûr des des infrastructures à à
entretenir donc ce n'est jamais gratuit
ensuite bien sûr
quand le la majorité sortante a supprimé
brutalement donc cette gratuité bien sûr
ça fait 200 voire 300 € pour certaines
familles donc c'est un coût exorbitant
il faudrait le moduler bien sûr en
fonction des ressources qui n'est pas
fait et et surtout se
consacrer pleinement donc qui a aider
ses familles voilà quand vous voyez
qu'il y a aussi des subventions qui vont
à l'étranger pour des écoles en geéorgie
150000 € sur pour des écoles en geéorgie
on pourrait affecter cet argent pour les
habitants du département alors ça amène
une réponse s'il vous plaît
syintthétique pour qu'on puisse avancers
sur autre d'être synthétique sur les
transports scolaires qui est un dossier
quand même lourd il faut que vos
téléspectateurs en soient conscient
puisque c'est près de 26 Millions
d'euros qui sont dépensés chaque année
un transport scolaire ça coûte par
enfant 1000 € par année nous observions
depuis des années et des années dans le
département de Lyonne comme dans tous
les départements français un
différentiel entre le nombre
d'inscriptions à la rentrée et les
effectifs effectivement comptés au mois
d'octobre 20 % descarts c'est ce qu'on
appelle les inscriptions de confort le
fait d'avoir instiller cette
notion de non pas d'abandon de la
gratuité mais de facturation partielle
puisque c'est 10 % des montants qui sont
facturé a fait refluer le nombre
d'inscription de précisément dans Lyonne
de 17 % donc tout ce qu'on avait vérifié
ailleurs en France c'est vérifié dans
Lyonne et si nous ne l'avions pas fait
et bien premièrement nous n'aurions pas
pu récupérer la TVA sur cette activité
ce qui s'élève à 1700000 la collecte
auprès des familles est de 2 millions
donc 3700000 donc quand j'entends
aujourd'hui des propositions de retour à
la gratuité et bien c'est six points de
fiscalité qu'il faudra mettre en face
pour obtenir l'équivalent j'ajoute et je
termine avec ça demander d'être bref
s'il vous plat c'est que la réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui a été faite sans
concertation avec les collectivités
territoriales et en particulier avec le
département
uégar au transport et bien nous coûte en
matière de transport
18800000 chaque année en plus donc voilà
la réalité des transports scolaires je
termine en disant puisque 95 % des
départements français ont mis en œuvre
cette participation des familles que
lorsque notre président de la République
Monsieur Hollande avait en charge un
beau département français qui était la
corise il a lui-même mis en œuvre cette
facturation partielle et le département
voisin je termine avec ça département de
la Nièvre que j'adore dans lequel je
vais très souvent dans lequel je
travaille et bien fait payer depuis
extrêmement longtemps les familles
Nivernais département socialiste et ben
voilà et ben voilà donc un peu de
cohérence messieur j'ai messieur
j'aiessieur voilàci s'il vous
plaît du transport routier au transport
ferroviaire un instant si si vous le
voulez bien parce que ça nous amène
aussi à la la décision du du conseil
régional toute récente de de supprimer
quelques quelques arrêts sur les lignes
TER dans dans dans le département on
voulait avoir votre votre point de vue
là-dessus gérardorme oui moi moi je oui
ça concerne en plus la ligne d'Avallon
donc ça tombe très bien effectivement le
le Conseil général a décidé de pour
améliorer pour améliorer c'est peut-être
paradoxal oui pardon le conseil régional
pour améliorer la liaison entre Avallon
et Paris notamment en matière de
performance parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
éta c'est pouvoir passer de 3h de train
à 2h30 et donc de le rendre beaucoup
plus compétitif c'était de supprimer
quelques arrêts de train mais ça veut
pas dire pour autant empêcher les gens
de prendre un moyen de transport puisque
le train serait remplacé par un autocar
ou des taxis sur cette sur cette ligne
donc effectivement on a vu une levée de
bouclier notamment de la majorité
départementale et de ses élus et de ses
élus commune concerné on a vu beaucoup
plus de gens dans les manifestations
organisées par les utilisateurs du train
qu'il n'y en avait qui prenz le TR mais
ça c'est un grand classique moi je crois
qu'il faut raison garder sur ce sujet le
le principal objectif c'est que les gens
puissent se déplacer on est bien dans le
cadre de la modalité aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que la solution qui est
apportée par le Conseil Régional après
négociation avec les élus avec les
usagers et cetera devrait donner
satisfaction c'est tout ce que je peux
dire là-dessus h et puis pas de
compétenence particulière en plus pour a
priori pour les conseillers
départementaux oui absolument peti
répond monsieur le moin peut-être non
non mais je crois que sur ce sujet là on
s'est mobilisé d'ailleurs conjointement
les uns et les autres il y a pas de
train dans le canton de saintvalerien si
on parle pas des C particul non non non
non non mais c'est vrai que c'était un
sujet un sujet majeur parce que un sujet
lié à la mobilité il y a des gens
effectivement qui qui doivent aller
travailler à valallon ou à auosser et
qui prennent ses trains un sujet lié au
tourisme un sujet lié au développement
durable finalement
aussi donc c'est vrai qu'on a pris ça un
peu comme un mauvais coup porté à la
ruralité et finalement on a l'impression
que même le conseil régional de
Bourgogne veut faire de Lyonne un peu
cette France périphérique cette
diagonale du vide et nous on est
vraiment voilà très mobilisé contre ça
des conseillers régionaux de l d'autres
mauvais coup réservés à la ruralité
c'est par rapport à la couverture
numérique du territoire on en parlera
justement ça une réponse madame madame
ZAR oui ben écoutez-moi en tant queill
j'ai voté contre donc je suis très à
l'aise sur ce dossier parce que nous
effectivement nous sommes favorables à
la au maintien de la desserte
ferroviaire du sud du département et de
l'ensemble des gares parce qu'on sait
très bien que quand on supprime le train
pour le remplacer par un quart ça c'est
vérifié partout ça diminue de 50 % on
perd 50 % en fait des usagers quit à ce
que le trajet soit plus
long écoutez dans les manifestation et
dans les rencontres qui ont eu lieu
entre usagers et puis représentants du
conseil régional les usagers ont très
bien expliquer leur problèm ils veulent
des transports et ils ont dit qu'il
n'étaient pas réticents à passer un peu
plus de temps dans le train du moment
qu'ils sont sûrs de pouvoir se déplacer
et quand on est dans un département dont
la population est vieillissante et bien
je crois qu'on ne peut pas se permettre
d'abandonner une partie du département
comme ça et de dire et bien il n'y aura
plus de train d'autre part le
l'argument comme quoi ça rallonge
énormément le trajet est un argument
très discutable puisqu'il y a aussi la
possibilité éventuellement d'avoir des
arrêts à la demande donc on sait on sait
bien que ça c'est un argument purement
économique et il y a des économies
certainement à faire dans des secteurs
qui sont beaucoup moins sensibles pour
la qualité de vie et pour l'attractivité
du territoire j sur ce sujet oui c'est
c'est un enjeu majeur un enjeu majeur
pour nos campagnes pour la ruralité qui
qui malheureusement donc se trouve bien
souvent
coupé bah par manque de transport par
manque de train par manque de car voilà
c'est un enjeu aussi pour nos écoliers
puisque beaucoup donc ne trouvent pas de
carart pour aller jusqu'à la gare ou
réciproquement donc il y a énormément de
difficultés et puis il faut parler aussi
de la sécurité dans les trains
c'estàdire que sur mon sur mon canton
que ce soit les trains qui arrivent à
ponuronne Villeneuve la guuillard la
sécurité est quand même un enjeu majeur
avec un grand nombre de jeunes venus de
de Scine etmarne qui je dirais soit qui
détériore soit qui agresse donc c'est
c'est une c'est une problématique
sur laquelle il faut travailler
aussi est-ce que vous savez où se trouve
cernisel dans le département pourquoi
cette question monsieur c'était pour
savoir si vous aviez une vraie
connaissance du département dans que
vous découvrez aujourd'hui vous parlez
de transport vous parlez de transp en
train pour les scolaires alors qu'il y a
des transports organisés par le conseil
général dans des bus je vois
manifestement que vous avez
une vousz secours de monsieurer c'est
bien
secours
c'était pour voir si vous étiez bien
format non je const que vous avez une
méconnaissance totale du département et
que vous parlez de ce que vous
conna regret c'est que Monsieur soit
passé
parudes en 2 secondes en 2 secondes on
sollicite le département de Lyonne
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du financement
de l'électrification du tronçon au la
roche on demande au département cas du
contrat de plan éat région 3200000
demain je remettrai sur la table des
négociations cette affaire c'est-à-dire
nous participerons département de
liyonne au financement de cette affaire
à condition que un certain nombre de
points soit revu pas fondamentalement
mais en tout cas qu'on puisse ménager un
certain nombre d'arrêts qui ne
rallongeront pas comme vient de le dire
Madame doucar et je pense que Gérard
deorme pourra nous rejoindre sur le
sujet r pas le tret on est tous d'accord
làus voilà donc c'est un sujet qui
reviendra en discussion après les
élections alors si vous êtes tous
d'accord c'est pas laine Julien je
répondre à Monsieur vill quandême sur
l'UDI vous savez pourquoi j'ai quitté
l'UDI monsieur Villet mais c'est à cause
de gens comme vous vous VO des barons
locaux qui sontèement déconnectés
finalement des préoccupations des
habitants c'est à cause de gens comme
vousce que vous avez ramené
au R qui occupe la place sans rien y
faire voilà un moment donné il faut
partir faut partir monsieur pb de la
France qu'est-ce que vous produisez vous
comment ça qu'est-ce que je
produis je travaille depuis mes 18 ans
Monsieur faites voilà voilà j'ai
travaillé j'ai fait des petits boulot je
vous passerai mon C si vousoulez je ve
le voir que vous faites ou fait toujours
de la photo c'est possible qu'on
revienne c'est
possible qu' à faire de la photo
monsieur monsieur
viler
sujet moi je au secours de
monsieurouons ou oui revenons
àer sujet avant de parler du contexte
politique justement peut-être est-ce
qu'on a abandonné les transports non
parce que j'ai vraiment des choses à
dire il faut qu'on avance mais on peut
rester autour du conseil régional si
vous voulez puceque on voulait parler de
la fermeture du
ou R et c'est une compétence du conseil
général et ça c'est une voilà et je
voulais dire qu'il y a de ce côté-là un
manque cruel parce que il y a beaucoup
de lignes de bus c'est vrai seulement
ces lignes de bus elles sont en fait
prioritairement réservées au transport
scolaire et elles ne circulent pas pour
une grande parti N qui sont prior elles
sont elles sont mixtes mais celles qui
sont mixtes elles ne circulent pas
pendant les vacances scolaires alors une
répse sil vous pl voilà il faut avancer
excuse-moiadame moi je vais compléter
parce que sur le volet routier
effectivement euh très mauvais coup fait
par l'État contrat de plan éat région la
déviation sud de sens qui était purement
et simplement zappé du contrat de plan
alors que le département a fait l'effort
de mettre l'argent sur la table pour
construire les ouvrage d'art on se
retrouve avec des ouvrages d'art en
pleine campagne avec la comm commune et
et et et donc l'état dit bah non moi
finalement je ve pas je pas vous aider à
financer cette déviation sud alors que
ça ça arrive au port de grond qui nous
ouvre vers la Chine vers vers le monde
vers vers vers l'exportation pour nos
forces économiques donc là aussi moi je
crois qu'il faut vraiment qu'on soit
très incisif pour très mobiliser pour
défendre no infrastrct un sujet sur
l'aménagement du territoire sur le
transport celui-ci oui c'està-dire
monsieur non mais on parle d'un
aménagement on parle pas du transport la
question de Chantal Doua très pertinente
portait sur le transport je rajouter que
nous participons extrêmement souvent à
l'établissement de convention entre des
communautés de communes des
transporteurs et le département des
conventions tripartites dans le casadre
de ce qu'on appelle les transports à la
demande et à chaque commission
permanente du conseil général on a des
dossiers de cette nature vous voyez que
c'est un sujet un sujet et 24 lignes
régulière madame doucar qui fonctionne
dans le département au-delà des
transports scolair et 15 de transport à
la demande ça je suis aussi au courant
mais on sait aussi que c'est quand même
une formule qui est assez peu souple
puisqu'il faut appeler quand même la
veille au soir avant 17h et euh moi ce
que je voulais ajouter c'est qu'à mon
avis il faut soutenir des systèmes qui
soient un petit peu moins rigide et il
faut développer quand même le
covoiturage il y a des dép appartement
il y a des intercommunalités qui s'y
sont mises qui réfléchissent y compris
dans liyonne aménager véritablement des
des espaces de
coiturage aux entrées d'autoroute enfin
dans les endroits les plus fréquentés et
puis soutenir aussi les entreprises et
les administrations à prévoir des plans
de déplacement pour limiter le
déplacement automobile c'est
un unot s'il vous PL sur l'enseignement
aussi parce que les collèg f aussi
partiigéoupand vous interrome merci
beaucoup on passe à l'enseignement si
vous voulez au collège notamment vous
avez cette compétence il y a des toutes
petites structures on a vu que le
Conseil régional proposait de fermer le
lycée bless Pascal notamment à men
est-ce que vous candidat vous avez
l'intention de rationaliser aussi les
collèges par exemple dans ce département
monsieur Delor écoutez aujourd'hui le la
carte des collèges dans le département
est plutôt bien
établi ce qu'on peut dire là-dessus
c'est qu' y a des collèges anciens
notamment dans le Nord et qui a un gros
travail à faire en matière de remise en
état de remise aux normes de les rendre
plus attractif parce qu'il y a une
modification de la population aussi sur
ces établissements aujourd'hui il y a un
déplacement il y a plus de gens dans
dans de personnes dans le nord du
département et je pense que les collèges
aujourd'hui qui sont dans cette zone du
département ne sont plus adaptés ne
répondent plus en tout cas à une qualité
d'enseignement mais il y a un autre
sujet en ce qui concerne
les collèges on a vu les deux derniers
établissements qui ont été construits
c'est le collège Clavet là Avallon et le
collège de noyère surserein on fait
l'objet d'un partenariat public privé
pour pouvoir le réaliser mais on se rend
compte aujourd'hui du cût exorbitant de
ce que ça coûte aujourd'hui au
département puisqu'il faut rembourser il
faut payer des loyers et je crois que à
ce niveau-là il y a un véritable
décalage entre la bonne intention qui
était la vôtre et la concrétisation en
matière de de gestion parce que là on
s'en va sur des dérapages très
importants ah bah ça c'est lespartenari
privé quelle est votre position sur sur
sur la question et sur l'entretien de de
de cette trentaine de de collèges dans
département 33 + 4 privés euh sur le
département bah toute façon oui comme
l'a dit Monsieur Delor mais des collèges
qui ne sont plus du tout je dirais au N
mais qui doivent être totalement je
réhabilités pour certains et ensuite je
trouve qu'on on a un manque de collège
quand même sur le département
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des des pareil
des zones qui sont privilégié là on
parlait du collège de migène voilà mais
finalement ce sont toujours les les
mêmes mêmes zones au lycée oui lycé oser
sens migène Saint-Florentin qui sont
privilégiés et les zones rurales qui
n'ont plus les transports donc un
problème pour les écoliers je voyais
dernièrement en puisit il y avait un un
jeune écolier qui devait faire 5 km par
jour voilà pour aller pour aller
jusqu'au collège bon c'est c'est
scandaleux donc c'est jeis qu'
une collège dans le nord du département
parce que la mographie est-elle que la
question se pose voilà d'un nouvel
établissement ou pas pour l'instant il y
a eu des extensions à blackard notamment
mais s'agissant justement de de la
puiser je trouve que c'est le très bon
exemple pour montrer la différence entre
une politique conduite par une majorité
départementale de tonalité de droite et
du centre et la politique du Conseil
régional le conseil régional ferme le
lycée professionnel amigène nous en
Puiset il y avait trois collèges de
peties taille et bien on a fait en sorte
de réserver les trois collèges en
rationalisant la direction mais en
maintenant ces trois collèges et donc
une proximité avec les étudiants et avec
les élèves donc je crois que là il y a
vraiment une différence fondamentale et
on le voit sur le terrain dans la vraie
vie non excusez-moi parce que non mais
là il y a véritablement une
désinformation donc je me dois
d'intervenir en tant que conseillère
régionale qui connaît un petit peu le
dossier du lycée Blais Pascal amigène
mais rapidement ben rapidement oui mais
enfin je peux pas laisser dire ce que
vient de dire monsieur le mooine parce
que le Conseil régional n'a pas décidé
comme ça de fermer le lycée BL Pascal il
y a eu il y a eu un incendie il faut
quand même le dire qui a détruit les
ateliers d'une section qui est la
section
microtechnique et la réouverture de cet
atelier nécessiterait l'injection de 3 à
4 millions d'euros ce qui n'est
évidemment pas tout à fait raisonnable
dans l'état du budget de toutes les
collectivités vous êesitaire vous êtes
austéritaire dis donc je ne suis pas
austéritaire je suis rationnel et le le
le conseil régional par ailleurs a un
plan dans le cadre de son schéma de
cohérence énergétique il veut
rationaliser l'occupation des des lycées
et donc là il va s'agir simplement de
rapatrier les autres sections sur le
lycée Louis davier à joignny qui est à 9
km et la section et à haoser et la
section de microtechnique va petit à
petit effectivement s'épuiser parce que
les professionnels du département ne
voient pas forcément d'intérêt à la
poursuite de cette de cette section donc
il s'agit absolument pas de dire qu'on
ferme un lycée c'est une décision tout à
fait conse général collège en quelques
mot s PL quelques mots soyons clair le
niveau d'entretien et d'équipement des
collèges du département est bon il reste
des efforts à accomplir notamment à
ponuri vous allez pas dans vos collèges
he c'est mal je ne fais que ça monsieur
je ne fais que ça vous y donnerai
rendez-vous je veux vous dire que
actuellement en milieu rural puisque
monsieur odoule parle du soutien au
milieu rural nous précisément nous
soutenons cette année la refflexion
entière la reconstruction entière de
deux collèges c'est celui de d'an sur
telon la croix des Ormes et celui de
chaabi le collège le rouge donc c'est
dire que nous sommes vraiment intéressés
au milieu rural et puis dernier point la
redistribution des cartes en matière de
compéten est complètement je veux dire
inexplicable pour nos concitoyens
puisqueon va maintenir au niveau des
conseils généraux le soin de poursuivre
l'action auprès des collèges et on va
laisser à la région les lycées alors que
tout le monde attendait soit soit que
les départements se voient confier
collège et lycée soit que les régions se
voient confier collège et lycée on
entretient alors attendez l'esprit de la
loi et de la réforme c'est bien de
mutualiser et de baisser les coûts et de
faire des économies or on va entretenir
adigon et AER les mêmes équipes en
doublon pour entretenir des bâtiments
passer les marchés donc voilà je trouve
qu'il y a là un rendez-vous manqué
j'espère que la
loi rien n'est encore décidé Ren n
encore déd et de toute façon quelle que
soit la décision prise vous auriez été
contre non pas du tout moi j'appelle un
regroup les deux compétences sous
l'égite de la même collectivité voilà
c'est dit reste il nous reste 5 minutes
à peu près avant midi euh il faut qu'on
vienne quand même à la politique parce
que c'est intéresse aussi no nos
téléspectateurs on voit finalement les
thèmes les gens parlent peu des des
thèmes contrairement à ce qu'on vient de
faire là pendant C cette émission ce qui
n intéresse aussi c'est donc le contexte
politique et le Front national notamment
qui qui augmente qui ne cesse
d'augmenter vous devez vous en féliciter
j'imagine Julien odoule on a vu ce en
début de semaine un sondage vous donner
30 % au niveau national ce qui VE
peut-être pas forcément dire quelque
chose dans chaque ananton mais quand
même c'est un signe quel espoirs
avez-vous justement par exemple vous sur
le département de Lon nous avons de de
grands espoirs puisque nous sommes le
premier parti de France mais nous sommes
aussi le premier parti de Lyonne dans
les intentions de vote en tout cas dans
les intentions de vote mais par rapport
au derniers résultats des élections
européennes donc nous onons fait 31 %
sur sur Lyonne nous sommes le premier
parti aussi d'implantation locale sur le
département puisque grâce à Édouard
Ferrand notre secrétaire départemental
nous avons 42 candidats donc sur les 20
un canton et nous avons de de grandes
ambitions ou nous pensons au moins
décrocher quatre cantons et je dirais
pouvoir défendre et proposer
l'alternative patriote donc au conseil
départemental donc à partir du 29 mars
mais avec quelle valeur parce qu'on peut
vous piser la question à vous tout à
l'heure monsieur viler fait allusion
mais vous venez-vous par exemple de de
l'UDI mais quelle valeur les candidats
du lointin maintenant l'UDI vous savez
au mois de décembre non non c'était
l'été dernier vous êtes pas informé
monsieur viler faut réviser vos fiches
faut toujours réviser ses fiches l'été
dernier pardon ok 6 mois alors avec
quelle valeur quelle valeur c'està-dire
et ben je sais pas est-ce que vous avez
les mêmes valeurs que Monsieur coutla
par exemple qui a fait parler de lui
cette semaine non monsieur coutla fait
partie de ces de ces exemples qui sont
tirés je dirais par la la caste
médiatique pour cibler euh quelques qui
écr sur son blog non non non bien sûrfon
ça remonte à 2011 il s'en est expliqué
il a jamais été poursuivi pour pour ses
propos euh je dirais si on regardait
dans chaque partie toutes les breobies
galeux je crois qu'on pourrait avoir des
surprises y compris à l'UMP et à l'UDI
euh il y a il y a un élément qu'on a
qu'on n pas encore évoqué mais qui est
peut-être de nature aussi à à peser sur
le le scrutin les révélations de d'Henry
dracour tout toute toute récente en
marge d'e d'une enquête ouverte sur des
des des possibles détournements de de
fonds publics au au au Sénat euh
manifestement le le sénateur dit qu'il a
perçu une rémunération pendant qu'il
était au gouvernement est-ce que c'est
c'est un événement qui peut nourrir les
les discours
antipolitiques ou en tout cas nourrir un
certain désaveux de de la politique et
est-ce que ça fait pas le jeu
précisément du du Front national
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine moi je crois pour
avoir vécu une campagne sénatoriale il y
a il y a 6 mois avoir fait la tournée de
Lyonne il y a une
envie je dirais de proximité
d'efficacité d'honnêteté bien sûr mais
je crois que d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'ai résumé hein ce tampon là qu'un
certain nombre de candidats portent
voilà je crois que il y a une attente
très forte préc d'efficacité et de
proximité euh et l'efficacité je le dis
parce que on a le sentiment et je pense
que c'est c'est ce qui fait aussi que le
Front national monte que bah finalement
que ce soit l'un que ce soit l'autre ça
change pas fondamentalement la vie et
cetera et et bien si il faut montrer que
il y a des hommes et des femmes sur le
terrain qui mettent les mains dans le
cambouille et qui arrivent à faire
bouger les lignes et donc je crois que
il faut lutter contre cette forme de de
désespérance forme d'abandon aussi qui
est ressenti par par certains iconis par
certains citoyens et c'est pour ça que
que notre notre devoir est grand et
qu'on doit être au rendez-vous des
résultats oui moi on a bien noté que
vous surfiez régulièrement sur le
phénomène d'abandon sur le phénomène de
rejet pour toucher les écturs laissei
finir je vais vous donner quelques
exemples et là vous pourrez pas dire le
contraire vous avez des candidats
partout vous en aviez beaucoup aux
élections municipales vous avez même
deux élus à Avallon que personne ne
connaît d'ailleurs il ne siège pas il y
en a plus qu'un qui siège après le 2e 3e
le 4e le 5e sur la liste se sont jamais
présentés ça veut dire qu'il y a une
politique de poudre aux yeux de votre
part avec des gens que vous présentez
mais je comprends que vos électeurs
soient déçus dans la mesure où ces
gens-là ne répondent pas en tout cas au
mandat qu'on leur a confié moi je crois
que vous êtes un illusionniste quelque
part je ne vais pas à l'encontre des
gens qui votent le Front national mais
je pense qu'il y a une véritable duprie
de votre part et que vous entraînez des
gens qui ne partagent pas du tout vos
idées vous parlez de d'é fantôme vous
avez monsieur bourreau qui est de votre
part de votre votre obédience monsieur
bourau personne l'a jamais vu sur le
canton de ponturon il rencontre pas les
Mair il rencontre pas puisque vous venez
d'arrivergory j'en témoigne lui il se
bat contre l'insécurité avec lui on va
mettre des caméras de vidéosurveillance
dans les
h dire que Dominique bourau lui il est
originaire du canton il est maire de sa
commune c'est accusation gratite vous
connaissz absolument ren raconter
n'importe quoi mais c'est V monsieur V
je voudraisevenenir à la question
quelqueses la question politique qui est
fondamentale et qui intéresse nos
concitoyens le front nationnal voit
effectivement son fond de commerce
augmenter mais c'est pas une surprise
c'est pas une surprise parce que nous
traversons une période de crise profonde
avec ses conséquences sociales
Jean-Baptiste leemine vient de dire que
un certain nombre de territoires se
sentent complètement orphelins de
l'aménagement du territoire de notre
République et les habitants de ces
territoires curieusement et
paradoxalement par rapport à des
dimensions qui sont celles de la
sécurité ont des réactions qui les pous
vers le populisme et moi je fais bien la
différence entre les électeurs du Front
National et ceux qui les représentent
c'est de mondes différents et j'ai
autour de moi des gens qui manifestent
ce désir nous le expliquons qu'ils font
faus
route ontér à de PRS les
réit onent dans 5 minutes à tout de
suite